estamos en la sede del partido
Revolución ciudadana en Quito con la ex
asambleísta Viviana veloz ella formaba
parte de la bancada correísta en la
asamblea nacional que cerró después de
la declaración de muerte Cruzada por
parte del presidente Guillermo lasso en
medio del proceso de juicio político en
su contra por presunto delito de
peculado precisamente Viviana veloz fue
la principal interpelante en este
proceso así que Viviana veloz le doy la
bienvenida France 24 Muchísimas gracias
por permitirnos este espacio para
mantener comunicados a la comunidad
internacional sobre lo que pasa aquí en
el Ecuador bueno Viviana yo antes que
nada le quería preguntar si usted cree
que este final de la muerte Cruzada es
un buen final para el proceso de juicio
político contra laso Más allá de que
este decreto es inconstitucional y
también ilegal es un triunfo para el
pueblo ecuatoriano es un triunfo para la
democracia porque los Ecuatorianos no
resistían este gobierno no podían
resistir hasta el 24 de mayo del 2025 y
sin duda haber declarado la muerte
Cruzada significa que el presidente no
tenía los votos para salvarse de la
censura y la destitución Pero además
también que en todo el proceso Nosotros
demostramos con pruebas que el
presidente tenía la responsabilidad
política de los hechos que se le estaban
acusando por parte de la asamblea y
también de una investigación que empecé
desde el mes de enero y que estaba
finalizando ya con el proceso del juicio
bueno acaba de hablar usted de
responsabilidad política Yo quiero ir un
poco más hacia adelante una vez haya
acabado el proceso electoral ustedes
creen en la culpabilidad de lasso
buscarán también llevarle por la
justicia ordinaria hay que recordar que
existen ya denuncias interpuestas ante
la fiscalía general del estado y lo que
esperamos es que fiscalía investigue que
no sea selectiva porque los Ecuatorianos
esperan respuesta y esperan también la
verdad de los hechos no solo bastaba con
la responsabilidad política sino también
tener las responsabilidades penales como
en reiteradas ocasiones yo lo manifesté
la responsabilidad política la da el
parlamento ecuatoriano la
responsabilidad judicial la tiene que
establecer tanto fiscalía como la
justicia ordinaria en materia penal Y
qué Esperamos que así sea bueno sin
embargo hay numerosos juristas que han
dicho que esa figura del peculado por
omisión de la que se ha hablado durante
todo este proceso no existe realmente
que les dicen ustedes a esos juristas
cuando eso es totalmente falso jamás
nosotros invocamos de un peculado por
omisión nosotros estábamos encausando a
Guillermo lasso por lo que está
establecido en el artículo 129 numeral 2
por el delito de peculado jamás por
omisión la distracción de fondos
públicos de haber permitido la
distracción de fondos públicos en la
empresa flopec para beneficiar a
terceros en este caso a la empresa
Amazonas tankers
pero ustedes fueron el partido más
votado en 2021 sin embargo en el
balotaje y Guillermo lasso ganó a su
candidato si se volviera a dar esa
situación si el candidato más cercano a
lasso porque lasso ha dicho que no se
presenta ganara la próxima presidencia
de la república entenderían que el
pueblo ha indultado entiende que no es
culpable lasso de ninguna manera al
presidente saliente Guillermo lasso el
pueblo ecuatoriano le revocó el mandato
desde hace muchísimo tiempo atrás y por
eso también se puede ver los resultados
de la consulta popular en febrero de
este año en la que el presidente
saliente perdió este referéndum y la
revolución ciudadana fue la gran
victoriosa Se ganó el referéndum pero
también ganamos las prefecturas de
alcaldías de las principales ciudades y
provincias del Ecuador ahora bien lo que
pasó en el 2019 es fruto también de una
polarización de querer instaurar un
frame de El correísmo y el anticorreísmo
y posicionar el odio Más allá de las
necesidades que hay que empezar a suplir
en la población ecuatoriana y Pilares
básicos Y de esa forma obtener un mínimo
pacto social Pero ahora vemos el
desastre de lo que fue esa mala decisión
y de un nulo ideológico que promovía
también ciertas bancadas que se dicen
que son de izquierda ahora nosotros
Contamos con el respaldo popular Más
allá de toda la persecución política que
ha sufrido la revolución ciudadana
tenemos certeza que el pueblo
ecuatoriano sabrá respaldar El Binomio
que nosotros presentemos para este
gobierno que será un gobierno de
transición y que tendrá una gran
responsabilidad de empezar a poner la
casa en orden Entonces como favoritos de
Cara a estas elecciones anticipadas
nosotros no es que nos vemos de
favoritos es lo que la gente nos dice en
las calles que con el gobierno de la
Revolución ciudadana Estaban mejor y que
lo que esperan es que ahora esté al
frente un binomio preparado capacitado
un estadista o un estadista con mano
firme pero que además ponga la casa en
orden en un año y medio no se podrán
resolver los problemas que tiene el
Ecuador pero sin duda alguna se podrá
empezar Ya a colocar las cosas en su
lugar y dejar preparado el camino del
gobierno que entre en el año 2025 otra
de las cosas que dice el pueblo
ecuatoriano Es que la asamblea tiene
gran parte de la culpa de esta situación
que se ha vivido hay una mala imagen
general de todos los asambleístas que ha
hecho mal también su partido para que se
haya dado esta situación si bien es
cierto hay una imagen negativa a la
asamblea nacional pero hay que recordar
que quien causó esta esta mala imagen
también es del presidente saliente
Guillermo lasso puso al frente al inicio
de la legislatura a la señora Guadalupe
llori que ha sido una de las
conducciones más precarias que ha tenido
el parlamento porque hicieron un pacto
entre la bancada izquierda democrática
entre la bancada del partido pachacútec
y dejaron de un lado al partido de la
Revolución ciudadana por sus odios y por
sus venganzas olvidándose que con eso no
se solucionan los problemas que en este
momento tiene el Ecuador y más allá de
las valoraciones que son institucionales
también se deben hacer valoraciones
personales de que hizo Cada legislador
cuántos proyectos de ley presentó ahora
también hay que recordar el presidente
de la república rompió todos los puentes
de diálogo y no pudo construir
gobernabilidad y que los problemas del
Ecuador el 80% están en la cancha del
ejecutivo y el 20% en la cancha de
legislativo la asamblea Sólo hace tres
cosas legislar fiscalizar y el control
político y es el ejecutivo el que
construye políticas públicas pero que
además también tiene la potestad de la
autonomía y la capacidad de invertir
recursos para trabajar en lo social y
así como también en la seguridad que es
el gran problema que en este momento nos
está afectando como país porque la
seguridad quería hablarle realmente es
uno de los principales problemas que
enfrentan este país con la situación en
Guayaquil y en otras regiones de la
república que es lo que propone ustedes
para mejorar esta situación en este
momento el Ecuador se ha convertido en
una fosa común con Himno Nacional
tenemos dos de las ciudades más
peligrosas del mundo como son Guayaquil
y esmeraldas Y qué es lo que proponemos
nosotros proponemos Un gobierno como el
gobierno que tuvimos en la época del
presidente Rafael correa tenía Los
indicadores más Bajos en tasas de
homicidio así como también trabajar en
invertir en presupuesto en materia de
seguridad y tener un plan de seguridad
también a corto mediano y largo plazo
trabajar en ejes como la prevención
inteligencia Y la investigación algo que
no hizo el presidente saliente que por
eso se ha profundizado los problemas que
en este momento existen no hay conmoción
social no hay conflictividad social
porque el crimen transnacional la
delincuencia común el narcotráfico le
ganó la batalla a este gobierno ahora se
necesita un gobierno con mando firme
pero que trabaje en esos ejes
fundamentales pero sobre todo que
invierten presupuesto precisamente hoy
el señor arauz que fue su candidato en
el año 2021 ha dicho que hay cosas
rescatables de la política de nayib
bukele en El Salvador Usted cree que
esto es una opinión personal del señor
arauz o hay una política de partido al
respecto es una opinión personal por
parte de nuestro compañero Andrés arauz
el manifestó que es una un
pronunciamiento
título personal Más allá de la postura
que nosotros tenemos como movimiento y
como partido político pero recalco se
necesita en este momento tener mano
firme mano dura con la delincuencia con
el narcotráfico que está azotando las
calles de este país y que no puede haber
tregua con estos antisociales y
necesitamos ese gobierno pero más allá
de eso también que se invierta recursos
en seguridad que se pueda potenciar y
dotar de lo necesario a la Policía
Nacional así como también se pueda
trabajar en estos ejes fundamentales que
de cierta manera a corto plazo van a
empezar a dar resultados porque la
población lo que quiere es seguridad Ese
es el principal problema que en este
momento tiene el Ecuador combatir al
crimen organizado Pero cómo se combate
al crimen organizado como se trabaja en
la mano dura sin caer en las denuncias
de falta de respeto a los Derechos
Humanos como está ocurriendo en El
Salvador trabajando con una política
pública de seguridad seria no trabajando
con una demagogia o no vendiendo humo o
queriendo hacer lo que no se debe hacer
porque hay que respetar también cierto
de estándares incluso que ya están a
nivel internacional constituidos pero
vuelvo y recalco es un pronunciamiento
que ha sido de nuestro ex candidato
presidencial pero que dentro del plan de
gobierno de este gobierno de transición
nosotros daremos conocer a la ciudadanía
Cuál será nuestra propuesta porque la
gente se decantará por quien presente un
proyecto de seguridad serio no un
proyecto de seguridad que no vayan a
cumplir sino que algo que sea
responsable y que tenga un compromiso en
este momento con el país y con la
ciudadanía estábamos hablando de su ex
candidato otras de las preguntas que se
hace la gente ahora mismo es que no van
a ser los candidatos de los partidos
tienen ustedes ya algún nombre concreto
el señor arauz también entra dentro de
esa lista bueno tenemos cuadros de
mujeres y hombres valientes preparados
capacitados que sin duda alguna harán un
papel muy trascendental dentro de este
binomio nosotros no queremos tener un
binomio nosotros queremos tener un
presidente de la república que lleve el
mismo modelo que teníamos en el gobierno
del presidente de la república Rafael
Correa y que dio resultados y que
Ecuador era reconocido a nivel
internacional por la por el Cómo se
luchaba contra la inseguridad pero
también cómo se trabajaba en el tema de
lo social y cómo se le dio dignidad a la
gente nosotros queremos ganar la
presidencia no solo minomio y por ello
tendremos mujeres y hombres preparados
al frente y que a partir del 31 de mayo
nosotros estaremos dando a conocer Cuál
será este binomio y dentro de esos
nombres de mujeres puede entrar el de
Viviana veloz cuando el presidente
Rafael Correa en medio de una entrevista
ha manifestado varios nombres entre
ellos también el mío pero recalco hay
que ser útil más no importante y
nosotros estaremos en el lugar que la
revolución ciudadana y la patria nos
demande en este momento de Cara a un
posible gobierno de su bancada Cuáles
serían las primeras políticas
importantes para el país de efecto
inmediato que podrían aplicar trabajar
en cuatro ejes que son fundamentales
seguridad salud
empleo y bienestar social con esa de esa
forma garantizando esos Pilares básicos
se puede obtener un mínimo pacto social
con la población recalco en lo que
insisto este gobierno debe empezar a
dejar la casa en orden para el gobierno
que llegará en el año 2025
a ustedes les invito que sigan con
nuestra programación
[Música]